this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you everybody I'm stunned by the
turnout here and i hope i will do the
your expectations justice when Angela
got in contact with me she asked for
something that would stimulate
discussion and and obviously it would
have something to do with soils and carb
cycling so the the general thrust that I
chose is this old thing that we all
learn at the very beginning of our
Scientific careers that this be careful
with correlations I think that that is
this this mantra that that is very early
in our scientific education as a maybe
maybe the data look good but but always
be mindful that you need to have some
sort of underlying explanation and I
thought I use this as the framework for
what I actually want to get across so I
don't want to tell you that you need to
be careful with correlations it may it
may look like I was going to do that
over the next let me say five or six
slides but don't don't don't fall into
that trap so what do I want to talk
about first of all the talk about carbon
cycling is replete with the use of this
word control and it pays to think for a
moment what what a control is so when
you want to know what whatever word
means you go to the dictionary don't you
and when you go do that then you find
that a control is defined as the power
to make decisions or the ability to
direct actions or inaction itself or
method law the limits the amount or
growth of something so or control its
perceived as something that is actively
doing something when we accept this
choice of definitions then we we are
immediately aware of the relatively
complicated nature of this thing control
when we have actions decisions methods
laws abilities then we have to accept
that this this this entity does this
concept of control is valuable dynamic
adaptive structure multifaceted I could
go on and you know if I put a little
effort into this so what I what I'm
trying to get across here is controls
are not single numeric values one number
is not a control but even a sequence of
numbers is not a control and even simple
mathematical functions or algorithms do
not qualify as control it's always when
you follow that merriam-webster
definition so now let's try to find the
connection back to carbon cycling when
people talk about carbon cycling event a
model carbon cycling then they often use
controls with the with the interesting
development that they multiply over the
years or the controls that are being
talked about increase in number we can
broadly distinguish environmental
controls which include drivers such as
moisture precipitation radiation heat is
a form of radiation but there's also
visible light ultraviolet light
high-energy radiation that might be
ionizing structure of the environment
can be parameterised total pore space
pore size distribution preferential flow
paths mineral surface chemistry the e
sources so all these are environmental
factors that are known to have an
influence on the cycling of car
oxygen availability you take the oxygen
away the array and things slowed down
dramatically alternate electron acceptor
us you take the oxygen away but you
provide nitrate and things keep going at
least were a larger part of the
microbial community proton concentrates
in other word for pH catalytic methods
organic co metabolites that will return
mineral born nutrients so something in
the order of 11 or 12 environmental
controls substrate controls so the this
refers to the fact that the the object
of decomposition has certain properties
which tends to be of relevance for the
decomposition process so which are these
properties bioenergetic potential how
much energy is stored in that organic
molecule how attractive is it from an
energy viewpoint to the decomposer
oxidation state of the carbon mainly
this is a important variable that
determines how difficult it is to get at
that energy but then also we we are not
just decomposing things for energy not
us and not the microbes we sometimes
need nutrients and in that case the
stoichiometry of the nutrients is
important and and this not just for the
the big ones the big mass nutrients but
also for a plethora of micronutrients a
similar bility so you are your compound
may be loaded with energy contain tons
of nutrients but it may have some other
feature that prevents it from being
assimilated the 11 really important
number here is molecular size when we go
above 600 Dalton we get into real
problems getting this compound through
the cell wall from the outside to the
inside and the the way these these
things are done in nature means that
thread like molecules have a much easier
to take an M so but not everything's a
thread and this is what we mean with a
similar bility and parametric
expressions of s mobility can be aqueous
solubility molecular size linearity
globular structure or these all these
features influence control range matter
turnover accessibility where is it is it
far the most from the decomposer as it
close by is it co precipitated by the
mineral phase kind of mired in in
concrete is it absorb encapsulated in
aggregate and that's another dozen or so
individual controls that we know have
something have the power to influence
the turnover prob so and I'm not done
yet organismic rosada yeah the
decomposers that those who are actually
doing the business they have different
lifestyles Gray's esprit de dos micro
rises free living fungi bacteria archaea
microbial diversity who's there who is
dominating the microbial community how
many of them are there how active are
they are they or dormant or are they
competing with each other massively are
the synergistic are there cheetahs there
is such there is such a thing those who
lie in wait for others to secrete all
the expensive enzymes and growth stage
physiology of microbes and especially
the chemistry of the extracellular
polymeric substances that they secrete
change as a function of gold stage with
an hour's ability to use oxygen that's
the that's our this is a second most
electronegative element in the periodic
table and it's the strongest electron
catch are you have a system that
contains oxygen you can make these large
energy gradients
really drive things and when you when
you cannot take advantage of this and
your energy gradient is only like that
such as between your substrate and I
event for example then the energy that
you can have is much smaller so you your
if you really want to have things turn
over quickly you want to have oxygen and
that is reflected in the biology of the
of the decomposers so some of them are
really specialized on this that but
others once in a while we run out of
oxygen and then you have those who are
absolutely unable to deal with oxygen
organisms that probably somewhat left
over from the days two or three billion
years ago when there was no oxygen free
oxygen but then there's all kinds of
integrals here so so so what I have here
is something in the order of 30 or if we
were to engage in a collective
brainstorm we would be able to come up
with another 10 or 20 within 15 minutes
I I'm pretty sure so the challenge then
is how to be constrained this what
matters who or what controls the control
is there a hierarchy of relevance do
they depend on each other it is the
control number seven of the same
importance in Cornell as it is in
corvallis and in the reactive it is a
respected soils of course so how have
people dealt with this I mean we are not
we are not the first who who realize
this this multitude of possibilities so
others before us have realized the same
thing and they have developed strategies
how to deal with this and one of the
strategies was the idea to look for a
master control for one parameter of a
one item that controls it all
the one ring and that one ring the first
big popular one ring is what we call
substrate quality that's that's the the
first suggest just suggestion of a
useful master controller that was
extensively tested by the scientific
community so I'm presenting two examples
for the application of this principle of
substrate quality in the function of a
master control you probably have all at
some point heard something about you
make substances and there is a paradigm
that's still standing paradigm that
these unique substances tend to have old
radiocarbon age because there is a
process that is called unification which
makes them highly aromatic and this then
explains their resistance to
decomposition which explains the high
radiocarbon age and this goes back to a
benchmark paper published in 1967 so it
needs a little explanation so you have a
graph with H on this axis hi age is here
1500 years the numbers are live it's
more but i'm so old carbon is e and this
is 1500 years 1500 years and then you
have an an index for aromaticity this is
the ratio of the light extinction at 400
and 600 nanometers this this is a way of
determining how many aromatic compounds
are in that specific solution so when
you are high on this axis the
aromaticity is low and when you are high
on this axis the the carbon is also so
the the young carbon or the young age is
following this red line and the that
that age gets older
as the aromaticity goes down Gregor
increases I'm sorry the the the brown
line goes down but that means the alamut
icity increases I'm time said just
practicing this for a couple of times
and I wasn't fit again so the at this
point I want to come back to my little
introductory remark about the importance
of correlation and our well joint love
for correlations me all when we see
something correlate like this the the
age goes up when aromaticity goes up
then we all love this we cannot we
cannot avoid that we really like this
type of observation and what we do then
is we inadvertently instantly invent a
model some sort of explanation and in
this case the explanation boss was
really plausible because we know that
aromatic rings require a lot of
activation energy to break them so it
makes it makes total sense for these two
parameters age and arrow mateesah t to
correlate but in order to to demonstrate
that they do indeed causally generate
this this is to decomposition one would
have to demonstrate that and actually
went one sentence ahead of myself here
was I was going to mention that this is
these ages here this is what we in
carbon cycling models consider the
passive pool you probably have heard
about the active the intermediate or
slow and then the passive pool so this
is this is what gave rise to this
passive pool idea 1000 1500 years of
turnover time so what are the issues
with causality here this this was
accepted and accepted relationship and
it wasn't accepted is
still an accepted model is it this type
of in fear vents informs the community
land model which is supported by NSF do
in which is the basis of climate
modeling at this time as we speak so
what is the issue with causality I'm
saying that the ideas behind the the
correlations used in the existing CLM
are not based on causality so she can
become bargain organisms have no way to
sense how much 14c or 13 c is in a
glucose or in a lipid they cannot make a
selection based on 14 c content or 13 c
content they recognize the glucose are
the recognized lipid and then they
decide whether they want to engage so
old age is not an argument for stability
it were an argument for stability if the
decomposer would have a mechanism to
select for young versus old which they
don't they go for a chemical
characteristic and not for a radio
carbon content or 13 c content fungi are
absolutely capable of decomposing
condensed aromatic rings there's a huge
literature and i just did not put it up
you just google PA ages and fungi and
you you get 10,000 hits or something so
the the mechanistic says mess
mechanistic assumptions behind that
little logical chain that i had on the
previous slide are not corroborated the
other thing or the third major argument
here is the early researchers were
working in canadian grassland soils
grassland soils and they had an
important piece of information they did
not have that we have it today so they
see this 14c age is a function of
aromaticity and they don't know a
important feature of these glass and
soils that we know today what is that
feature that the aromaticity in these
soils does not come
from whatever that you much occasion
process represents it was supposed to be
here the map so you have these grassland
soils which has Sona soils they are all
along the song somewhere between the
20th and the in the 50th parallel
actually a few down here in Argentina as
well this is a map using the FAO solid
systematic so it has the Peoria nose in
disgust oh no James these soils are
broadly equivalent to the u.s. all
taxonomy Molly sorts these grasslands in
the native states they burn regularly
and that loads them up with black RBC
means black cob so here's the data so
that this study is based on 28 soil
profiles very vigorously investigated
with radio carbon 13 see Marcus for
black Tom and you find that there is
something of the line was not drawn here
but there's something of a correlation
between the black carbon and grassland
swords and the carbon stock in these
soils and the takeaway message here is
that grassland soils contain between one
and five kilograms of black carbon which
is more or less a concentration of
aromatic rings so we are we are facing a
long-standing paradigm and there is
abundant evidence that the mechanistic
underpinnings are no longer valid let me
put it that way oh yeah and this was
published by rajan of in 2010 so so
let's leave the the long slow pull the
2000 year pool behind for a moment
there's another example of this attempt
to use a master control to describe
carbon turn over and that is the
paradigm that litter decomposition where
it should be a function of the lignin
nitrogen ratio
this is a app salute citation classic
here Melillo at our 1982 and this was
the work where it was shown for the
first time that the biomass remaining
after you expose litter for a certain
amount of time well let it decompose the
amount of litter that remains after time
X is a function of lignin nitrogen ratio
basically you have high nitrogen the
litter is decomposed quickly and you
have low nitrogen or the inverse is
literally mean high lignan then the
letter goes away much slower so which
leads to this this general paradigmatic
statement that litter decomposition
depends on lignin content there is one
one caution that one should immediately
become aware of when one looks at this
graph so if this is a categorical
predictor then the green and the blue
should be on top of each other but
apparently this relationship can be
modified in here we run into this issue
with our assumption that a master
control may help us to get a handle on
the multitude of controllers if for
whatever reason I want to be able to
distinguish between ecosystems
apparently just one control is not going
to carry the day so this is pi by the
way the experimental evidence that gave
rise to this idea that we should have a
slow pool in carbon cycle models so
because this type of material turns over
on an annual multi-annual timescale
10-20 the
the issue with this is not only that the
green and the blue we are not on top of
each other the issue is also that this
old assumption lignin is only decomposed
after the labile or n containing
organics have been used up so this is
the this this back in staff 1980 this
litter decomposition models as you have
the mass of the lid of the blue line my
mass on this axis time on this axis as
as time progresses the letter comes down
the mass comes down and the the
underlying idea verbalized here was that
the lignin doesn't respond until the
label stuff which would be the area
under this curve here under up until
that that is decomposed so the idea the
bugs decomposers go for the easy stuff
first and then they have used that up
then they eat the basically the ether
candy and then they go for the potatoes
and and and again this is this is
somewhat plausible because it it is in
line with some of our own behavior just
was talking about the candy and up again
no this is we have evidence that
policies of this kind can work in this
in this fashion but is it is it actually
what is going on here and then there is
new research that shows vigorous lignin
decomposition is going on only as long
as there are these easily decomposable
things so the the mass loss now again
the little mass loss whole little mass
loss described by the blue line but the
the lignin gets decomposed here at the
at the font when you have these things
in order to help decompose the lignin
but when you run out of the accessory
the so-called co metabolites
then the resources to do business with a
lignin are no longer there and then the
line flattens out published in 2011 so
and the the old model 1980 so it's 30
years and new evidence has come around
in both cases it's it's it's not my
intention to to criticize the our
predecessors but it's my intention is
rather to point at the need to be
careful with these Carol correlations
and don't trust them too much because if
we do we might miss the the things that
are really going on so yeah and that was
going to point that out which I believe
I did so is substrate quality and
appropriate master controller well based
on the evidence I have just presented I
hope you can join me in saying that is
probably not so in and if if that is not
so then is there is there may be some
other master controller and here we
partner come to work that was published
in 99 ATR 81 so large differences
between the turnover rate of particular
compounds in liquid microbial colleges
and in soil indicate that soil provides
a measurable degree of protection so
that those who set out to get a handle
on the controls focused on the substrate
and but then somebody realized the soil
controls the matrix of the soil controls
decomposer as liquid decomposition as
well so you have you may have the
substrate somewhere here but then it
matters what kind of matrix this
substrate interact with if at all
interestingly look at that date that
that that kind of thinking came out more
or less at the same time but the
substrate control idea was way more
feeling to the scientific community
liked it much better didn't really want
to deal with this matrix and mineral
stuff for a while at least so until 1997
Margaret my former boss was lucky with a
nature paper that was tight at Mineral
Point all of soil organic carbon storage
and turnover so this this then is an
example for for an attempt to address
some of the shortcomings that the
substrate quality idea head by replacing
it with a better master controller
problem with that approach was that it's
not exactly a straightforward predicta
EDA so and it would be so if you take
mineral components from the plaintiff
and soils here this is the clay fraction
then you you have to accept that the
ability of place to associate with
carbon is much different between the
soils so you can't just say which
actually the the century model does take
clay content and use that as a rate
modifier it matters a lot what kind of
clay you have in there so what do we
make out of this what's what where do we
go from here a contest of the master
controls does not seem to be the best
strategy here so remember in the
beginning I took some time to show that
there is no problem to come up with at
least 30 or 40 individual factors that
would qualify as some sort of control so
picking one and and focusing on one of
these controls is is not apparently not
the best strategy and why because in
both cases the evidence in support for
the importance of that control was
largely correlative that it
the researchers saw this correlation the
lignin nitrogen ratio and the amount of
of litter left perfect you know straight
line you go out do some experiments out
there and and you can have 10 data
points and you get a straight line how
often does that happen it must mean
something doesn't yeah and but but the
fascination with this type of result
then makes us makes us so confident that
we do not dig deeper so are we doing
enough to dent if I understand
mechanisms and causes behind the
assumptions that we use to inform carbon
cycle models I'm positing here we are
not and you are the generation that has
to change that brings up the issue of
causality so how do we get at causality
in carbon cycling but what what are ways
to make this work so that control is
actually our descriptors the the thing
that we need to understand we don't need
another label we already have 30 or 40
what what we need is understanding of
the system the machine the engine
reciprocating or turbine that that type
of understanding is what we need and a
good way to approach this well the way
that I am too I am I am proposing here
is to look for where the soil comes from
evolutionary adaptations so the number
relevance connectivity of controls our
30 catalog of 30 controls can they be
seen as a consequence of systems design
which would have if this in any way
works out it would mean if you get an
idea of the principles behind systems
design how is the the soil as a place
where carbon is processed how how is
that designed how is
laid out what are the guiding principles
if we know that we may be able to get at
the causalities that we are missing in
these old correlations so what I'm
saying here is in disagreement with the
views that geologists have about soils
geologists take soils as the interface
between a planetary body and what is
beyond and they do not require life to
be involved in the formation of soil
this understanding of soil when I say
the soil evolves but the ecosystem goes
back to this idea of the brand I'm sure
others as well have put forward that
when soil formation really took off on
this planet when plants started to
evolve and when the LJ came out of the
water and inhabited the land that is the
moment where we should start talking
about soils so if we follow that premise
and again the geology community folks
who like to find soils on Mars they they
have to do without trees and out oats
and so that's a different view of things
evolution has created flow through
reactor systems with unique reactor
design and carbon processing strategies
so that would be the causal the key to
causality reactor design com processing
strategies so something like 400 million
years ago a few algae started to inhabit
the land surface the these little algae
evolved into potter plants which
developed proto hoods which by the way
from the first day were working together
with mycorrhizae fungi and bacteria
because they were there first and so as
a result the matrix gets transformed and
when you allow the plants to become more
complicated
the more powerful as biogeochemical
machines then you get these systems and
it is relatively easy to envision that
when you change the ecosystem here that
would have effects on how the soil is is
functioning they have different inputs
you have different quantities of inputs
you probably have a other biota and so
you get a different type of reactor
design and different carbon posting
strategies that now means the controls
are the result of how they the system
works you don't approach the problem by
asking what does temperature due to the
system you approach a problem by saying
how does the system work oh if I raise
the temperature to 50 degrees that means
such as such so it's a a reversal of the
line of thinking the basis for this is
the the fact that within any ecosystem
there's coevolution of above ground and
below GaN biota the decomposers are
there because of the plants that's the
idea behind this and it's not my idea it
would at all the interesting paper the
the signs papers only four or five pages
but this supplemental information i
believe 70 so you really so this is it
sighs evolved to decompose organic
carbon at the raids and in the sequence
is required to support the ecosystem
that that puts into question ideas like
oh i have a certain lignocellulose that
should decompose at a rate that is
typical for lignocellulose that's what
our mothers do right now 76 days
lignocellulose if the system has evolved
in us to to deal with league no solid
cellulose in a certain way then the
system determines the characteristics of
the system determine how long this
league no cellular
cause takes to be decomposed so it's no
longer an inherent property of the lingo
cellulose so system evolution here is a
dune and beautiful Oregon and this is
grad student other than Gallo taking a
picture and only about 500 meters away
from this dude is the older dune and you
see how that soil has devolved has shown
some some e horizon ABS horizon so
that's an incipient spotter soul this is
a very early and anti soul and in the
course of this development is there's
change of the mineral matrix it's
consumed minerals are destroyed new
minerals are formed and things are
rearranged in the soil structure is
changed so the Yak Toa design this is a
different reactor than this it does
different things and that those things
that they that are happening different
here influence the turnover time of the
organic matter yeah this this whole
matrix issue must be seen not as a
static entity but as a dynamic adaptive
part of the ecosystem so the mineral
matrix is actually shaped by the biota
which is which is the the major force
that that makes the soils function in
different ways so a very good idea of
how this works is you need water we all
agree with this water comes slightly
acidic because you have co2 in the air
which dissolves in the water and that
makes it mild acid this then allows for
weathering of the minerals you can have
small reactive battling products and
then they can be mineral partners of
mineral organic associations and the
intensity along this path varies what
you get here moisture
also allows things to go microbes and
plants and then when when plants go for
example they generate root exudates
which are acidic really acidic and that
then augments our amplifiers processes
down here so you have more growing here
you have more change here you get that
you get the idea you you make this a
private active part you get of the bad
word here you miss because it's in every
book this can be decomposed and you
again making something acidic and this
again then influences the properties in
the shape of the mother may so a highly
dynamic system you'll take vegetation
out you change the intensity of policies
you mess with the microorganisms you
change the intensity of policies and it
should it should illustrate the
contention that this is not very well
predicted or described by saying lignin
or cellulose are are decomposed within
50 days but yeah I changed the
importance of any of these arrows and
that number will not have any connection
with reality so where are we currently
search practice is centered on
understanding controls and the
interactions which can be paraphrases
understand the control to understand the
system that is how we all have been
bought up this is a lower modulus work
they want us to figure out how a
algorithm that describes how the control
equation influences turn over time but
would it not be better if we accept that
controls and their relative importance
evolves with a system to put more effort
into understanding systems design and
such in a way that we can derive the
relative importance of controls for the
governance of the system that would turn
the thing around understand the system
in order to understand the importance of
the control so if you are interested in
temperature sensitivity of organic
matter DK well you need to understand
how DK works and then you will be able
to understand what happens when you
manipulate the temperature the way we
are approaching this right now is from
the other end systems design so what
does that mean solids are different so I
like I just said in corvallis we have
different soils then you guys have here
so there is a an obvious difference
between soil type but even within one
soil you can identify regions where the
the posters regime is completely
different so let's look at the little
layer here this is a loose pile of
substrate that's like walking into
starbucks in the morning everything's
they are just grab it well aerated elect
oxygen plenty no need to come up with
any fancy Physiology or so easily
accessible to mobile decomposers yeah a
a force that we tend to forget that I
frequently mezzo fauna those are the
ones that chew the large pieces down to
the size where the bugs can then do bit
so they are abundant here they can call
among the leaves and twigs and they they
are fast they are usually the first ones
on the scene susceptible to
perturbations and to fluctuations of
driver Atlee folds down crashes on the
forest floor all this this little
paradise is is annihilated well it
doesn't rain for three days the moisture
holding capacity is basically not
existing so it rise out so it the
amplitude ecological amplitudes are
large you need adaptations for that
basically
let's go a little further down a horizon
this is actually the region where you
can say the ecosystem does its recycling
so this is the recycling facility of the
ecosystem you have an active input of co
metabolites foolio text dates so the
plants they have they have no endless I
may know the plant cannot think and an
ecosystem it does not evolve in a
direction chosen by the ecosystem it or
adaptive so you excuse my language when
I say the plants can support business by
putting exudates out there are
regulatory mechanisms that allow them to
do that is it in an adaptive fashion the
point is that as long as you have these
placards fine words you can really speak
up things yeah you have you have
something that is absorbed and protected
or it's a large chunk you can you can
support decomposition processes but by
meta inputs you have a wide choice of
catabolic pathways everything's
everything's going here you have access
to catalytic methods and reactive
surfaces because you're already in the
soil you don't have that in the same
extent here in the little layer because
you don't have the metals and you don't
have the minarets and the oscillations
in oxygen supply our somewhat dampened
because the moisture holding capacity is
much higher than than here but it's it's
it's still it's still cycling once in a
while you go through a redox cycle and
you can recycle those little sensitive
metals that you that you can use utilize
as catalyst only when you get down here
then you are in the desert but that is
again that qualifies as a completely
different operating conditions condition
for a reactor low substrate
concentrations a bit of substrate here
been here a bit here a bit here and the
microbial in the center how is this
supposed to work you cannot do very
quick organic matter turn over under
such conditions
few organisms lack of co metabolites
because notes anymore we use pore space
because often you have clay formation at
those depths and that will clog your
pores it's difficult to get oxygen down
there and you have the issues of
accessibility that I just pointed out so
this is what I mean with understanding
how the system works and then ask
yourself now when I am let's say I am in
this in this in this desert in the inlet
in a sub soil and I put junk of wood
down there is it really appropriate to
say this turns over in 76 days as a as a
substrate specific parameter I don't
think so so now is here to understand
controls on carbon cycling are relying
too much on correlative evidence for
grass may come from bottom-up approaches
that seek to infer the causality line
isabella giving you hear the what you
already hurt in your first statistics
class so but I what I really want to
emphasize is it's worth to to accept the
fact that so let's do not just look
different but also work different
especially when it comes to carbon
cycling the next generation of models
and the next generation of scientists
needs to emphasize the causalities
behind soil process don't do the same
thing that our fathers have done now
when even you see that slight line okay
I have a slight line great that
certainly going to be a paper but be
honest to yourself yeah be honest to
yourself do I really understand what's
going on here have I tested whether my
assumption is really the the mechanism
behind this or am I am I going the way
of cheap sales and if you're ever in a
position to support some sort of
modeling exercise be especially careful
with the causality thing yeah like a
golden sentence to conclude and
paradigms must be continuously challenge
and check for compliance with course
that is it doesn't deadly beautiful
oculus fight okay thank you for your
attention well I need to admit that i'm
not a modeler and i also need to admit
that i have enormous confidence in the
possibility of technological advances so
i remember that when i entered the fear
20 years ago we modeling exercises were
done on super computers today that you
don't need them one of the major
constraints was storage space at that
time and i understand his constraints
have gone down but i also remember that
the computational complexity of models
was an issue and so not knowing what the
most recent developments in this field
are i think the the argument that the
models need to be simple which i
completely understand and i think there
is no reason to try to over explain
things we we know this from other
phenomena when you can explain something
using three variables and there is no
need to throw 30 variables into the
picture in fact principal component
analysis is a tool that we all often use
to bring down the number of variables
because it's then easier to make sense
of what you see so my attempt to talk
around your question is now going on for
one and a half minutes
but what you what you get from from this
is I think there is probably some some
slack in what on the computational side
can be done so I think we should not be
afraid to add parameters or add
algorithms to our modeling attempts but
to what extent that can be realized is a
little bit beyond my area of expertise
that okay thank you so I have friends I
have model of friends and they have they
have played with not just decomposing
organic metal but breaking organic meta
down into a certain functional
categories and that seemed to be a
useful approach that has been published
last year i think in geo scientific
model developments obscure journal yeah
so if you are interested in detail i'm
happy to share the sauce yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu